[Music]
y'all know I'm a big history buff I love
to study the ancients yeah you like the
cheese me and I yeah right but I always
wanted to ask you guys a question
because I always fantasize this all the
time but what era would you live in if
you could live in any [ __ ] the
question is can I choose my race
[Music]
obviously because it's gonna be yeah I
want to be part of the astok tribe for
sure yeah they're [ __ ] dumb kicking
ass before the Europeans came and made
you sick sacrifices and stuff that's I
mean and they played they played soccer
game of death I'm royalty she's taking
it with honor
you'd be royalty oh I could change you
could change your gender you could
change your race you could change
anything you just [ __ ] implant
yourself anytime right it's gonna be a
[ __ ] dinosaur if you want to be
Renaissance yeah yeah just a tree
fighting your glidin Renaissance era if
I don't be a cop all the Ninja Turtles
existed are you thinking we teleport
there with like stuff like that right
after rid of James yeah yeah so it
doesn't have to be real anymore because
you just said I could be a dinosaur I
mean it was a real dragon but I thought
he made like as ourselves ankle that I
added
I added that no no because yes about the
race thing so I was like well okay I
guess
huh well sex and just choose right
before Aztecs I think got it worse the
dinosaur they have a me or crash into my
[ __ ] planet and I leave oh that's
what happened didn't it I believe slowly
because that's guys blacked out and all
the vegetation died let's see I thought
it was a slow [ __ ] drawn-out death
well would you rather have smallpox
because they dirty her pants came and
coughed on you I'd rather be here now
yeah I like now better when you don't
know what's gonna happen okay what if we
were the Aztec yeah you see our [ __ ]
heads our feather headdress or like a
[ __ ] the way we're dress we'd look
sick I'm allowed to but I would rather
go in history I would choose oh yes your
history you know something we can
actually somewhere okay you can chew
ours
you could chew like it's it and you know
everything that you know now right so
you but you could choose your race your
gender your position whatever see you
know everything you know now which means
when you went to the Renaissance era you
know that it smells bad you know what
cleanliness okay it's like you're
[ __ ] right when you first [ __ ] it
smells bad but then you get used to it
you see in the bathroom longer you of
all people smelling [ __ ] you're not
gonna last I picture this fool like with
all he senses now we played a take a
party episode where we're shooting [ __ ]
in his mouth has you're shooting your
own spit ball into his mouth and you
through
not I threw up when Dimas drink
everyone spit no you do your ball went
into those Matthew [ __ ] and yeah you're
not gonna make it in the Renaissance I
never want to play [ __ ] up birthday
every [ __ ] I'm just thinking of like
watching you know the cool poetry
getting drunk off widest eyes I feel
like when science isn't as bad as
medieval medieval is when it was if you
want to see some people fight and get
the head chopped off you should go to
like the gladiator era that's um I feel
like if the Roman [ __ ] Renaissance is
like it's like a good a good balance of
both yeah so had that we also had the
lovey-dovey like romantic one nah man
like I'm not gonna give you a shitty
situation where it's like yeah you could
choose any era but you're a slave in
that era you know it's like why would I
want to go there what you're like yeah
you get to be a part of the Mongols but
guess what you're a sex slave to the
Genghis Khan tribes you know like Nadeem
just making love all over again to the
wazoo be dope dude damn it throne though
have you seen what ancient girls look
like they don't shave if they look like
the chicks and Game of Thrones if they
look like that
I'm sure they have high well cousin back
then they also thought thicker women
were like the more ideal and that's what
everyone favored back then I would have
you seen the nude like statues like you
know like the old-school Roman and Greek
and [ __ ] like that's what healthy was
yes they just look like normal girls
today Yeah right but they're not to me
they're not like into the models but
they kept a little pouch you ever notice
like they yeah they got that lady good
yeah yeah that's true
the diet was carbs but the guys didn't
change much that I yeah what happened
what happened why did the guys look Jack
in the Medard they're not Jack I don't
like that Oh some of the girls are
jacked like in the in the pictures I
mean
[Laughter]
I'm only mentioning this because I went
to a museum recently in in Europe and
then though I was like damn the women
like the Greek statue like women they're
[ __ ] strong looking too and it got
nice titties so I was like damn but
they're more boxy they don't have the
hourglass like our times body that we
find ideal and women like they're like
they're more like Spongebob Squarepants
kind of rectangular yeah I got the pouch
to get a little bit more I said I would
choose maybe like the 40s 50s just
because I can still because my mind now
is going there a lot more with like the
music and like the art and all these
things I can enjoy I'm not listening to
some classical music [ __ ] from back in
whenever you know or like though that
[ __ ] goes off I need the drums I can't
do it without the drums hand there's
some drums oh that's what I would like
to do is go back in a day and hear the
music because we don't have any like
written record or whatever like the
classical music we had you know it's all
written and people can still play it
today but past that what did they sound
like I'm [ __ ] curious man okay so
like now if you go back right you know
stuff you know today will you try like
influence our and like teach them how to
do stuff or I teach them how to clean
and bathe that I will take full [ __ ]
advantage dude I would like make them
think I'm a god how are using magic
tricks and [ __ ] like what like what well
like I would learn magic
[Laughter]
and then magic tricks I could predict
what's gonna happen cuz like the era and
[ __ ] like I could be like Nostradamus
yeah you're like Caesar using your
[ __ ] up guys yeah it's gonna happen I
don't think you're gonna live very long
yeah that's true they're like either way
to Barnum yeah what's the guy that would
go and entertain the king like that oh I
learned some [ __ ] about it yesterday
what I realized is those guys are
[ __ ] okay
there's a lot of [ __ ] that we don't know
about them and and it's like it's just a
bunch of jokers right huh but they were
the only ones that were allowed to talk
[ __ ] to the King to their face so but
they they were so good like a comedy
that they were allowed to do it funny
and they can't be killed so they could
criticize the King they could do that
and then the King would actually ask the
the gesture is all the time for real
advice because everybody around him was
afraid to be killed and all that stuff
and then the Jester could just be like
man you [ __ ] nut people don't like
you and then don't make a joke out of it
they'll make a song out of it don't pay
a good joke yeah and what's crazy is
sometimes these guys would be it's like
it's so weird cuz Dobby they'll be
taking into battle right wearing the
[ __ ] thing in their neck those guys
were called fools
uh what yeah so the gesture that we see
with the [ __ ] goofy ass hat in well
they're called cools Oh what's a gesture
then gesture is like well today we yeah
he's like the he's like a court jester
like he's he's like yeah he knows how to
entertain
he's like an NVA and he's an MC he
breaks bad news to the king yeah yeah in
a funny way your wife died
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah and they would they would go to the
battlefield and they gave strategic and
by sometimes who the [ __ ] are these
people they're like a [ __ ] to me I
think they're guys that tell the truth
or like they're like they're funny but
they can tell the truth and then they
give it to you straight but then they
have a lot of tack on social skills
without hurting your feelings and so
some of these guys there their morale
boosters too so don't be taken into
battle and some of them would ride in
front of the army so they could it as a
mental tactic to [ __ ] with the other
crew like hey this clowns riding on the
front they're not afraid of you and the
clown will just talk [ __ ] so that will
roast I love that it's a structure yeah
I'll get roasting that they're roasting
the other army right and they're talking
[ __ ] because what they're hoping is the
emotional soldiers that are like out of
control would break the line that's not
cool time where they don't have cannons
in like yeah stuff nothing is shoot for
ya do get scoped out really just like
[ __ ] this whoops but I was like damn cuz
I thought court jesters were a bunch of
dumb little jokers and then when I found
out the history about it I was like yo
that's not a bad gig how'd you find out
the history says that because I watch a
lot of history [ __ ] right so they're
like the real role gesture nothing pops
up for me like that yeah like when
you're watching YouTube right don't they
have like recommend a recommended yeah
so like the real role of a gesture and
[ __ ] and I was like dude I take that job
all day and then if you're really good
at what you do you get a mansion you get
your own servants and then all you do is
work on your comedy stand-up gig and all
that strategic planning because you're
like dog
yeah it's like a whole roaster planning
what if this YouTube channel attacked
it's called fake history drunk history
why is wild yeah I'm learning a lot of
fun [ __ ] though but I just wanna
I wish what I can do is like you know
like we can play sims right we could
play
create all these characters I wish I can
have like the power to go all right
today I want to be a Mongol today I want
to be like you know in a Tang Dynasty or
some [ __ ]
well like I want to I want to be one of
the guys that work for Catherine the
Great or whatever I was like what's
world yeah that's like going to a theme
park where you're actually transported
there and actually like live the life
that would be amazing
we'll get there it sounds like in the
next five years some shits really gonna
mop up I'm traveling are these the West
world experience I'm traveling I want to
do real time traveling while changing
your gender and race wow that's crazy
like ready player one style with that I
like that one [ __ ] altered carbon
remember that a little bit
[Laughter]
[Applause]